dix huit ans il ya six ans on m'a fait
ça c'était l'horreur c'était terrible et
dans mon monde de oui oui j'aimerais
tellement que chroniqueur télé
une animatrice télé quand elle est en
poste qu'elle aille dire voilà cabanon
son patron il mais voilà c'est pas
facile parce que sinon tu perds ton
boulot c'est ça je reviendrais fallait
jamais seul dans mon monde de oui oui
oui ça m'est arrivé alors mais on dit
oui ça m'est arrivé complètement je vais
vous raconter alors dans les rues
d'accra quand on se marre avec des
garçons voilà ça parle un peu cul ça me
dérange pas on va se marrer d'entre nous
au calme mais là j'ai vécu quelque chose
de très différent et et d'assez
difficile il ya 12 13 ans je commençais
à la radio j'étais au sein suis pas avec
moi non c'est après avec moi non c'est
yahia 9 10 ans alors oui et c'est un
très bon groupe radio parce que
justement ils ont viré cette personne
ensuite croquer ces questions là moi je
n'avais pas dénoncer parce que j'avais
eu peur en me disant moi je suis une
petite réaliser quoi il sait pas ce qui
s'est passé c'est que au départ ils ne
me parlaient pas et ne m'adressaient pas
la parole
il ne me disait pas bonjour si je venais
à plat pas en talons non il me disait je
ne vous dirai pas bonjour je ne vous
parlerai pas si vous êtes en basket mais
travailler chez sarenza mais en fait il
voulait absolument que je sois en talons
et il me demandait de marché devant lui
quand j'avais mes talons et une fois il
m'a convoqué dans son bureau vous non il
m'a dit vous montez dans mon bureau tout
de suite et donc là alors c'est sûr
c'est pas moi j'ai pas une bonne chose
[Rires]
s'il arrivait dans son bureau et c'est
une atmosphère qui fait vraiment peur
c'est à dire que là ils tournent autour
de moi il me parle il a une voix qui est
glacial il touche le bout de mes cheveux
il touche juste un petit peu mais
jean-louis david mais là il me demande
si jamais je connais le bondage quoi bon
me demande si je connais le bondage
moi il me demandait il me demande ce que
tu connais déjà d'aller porter secours
aux banques
je lui dis non je ne sais pas ce que
c'est il me dit eh ben vous retourner
tout de suite dans votre bureau vous
regardez sur google ce que c'est faux et
vous roulez dans mon bureau pour me dire
ce que vous en pensez
et là je regardais je vois et vêtements
c'est une pratique sexuelle on doit
s'attacher et s'est lancé avec des
cordes et donc là moi j'ai du but je
débute la radio et je dois remonter dans
son bureau pour lui dire ok bah j'ai vu
ce que ça vous avez vous êtes remonté
lui dire eh ben je suis revenu et j'ai
essayé
mais visiblement je vous aime et le
saucisson et j'ai essayé alors c'est pas
drôle
je reconnais c'est pas drôle ce que j'ai
dit ça me ressemble l'humour c'est pas
ça chez moi mais j'ai essayé de trouver
une pirouette pour n'en avait jamais
parlé
si vous en avez parlé après et je me
suis dit moi stagiaires ou lui qui à la
direction qui est ce qui saute c'est moi
donc je n'ai rien dit à ma direction et
j'aurais dû parce que c'est une très
bonne radio et qu'ils ont viré peu de
temps après sept personnes qui se sont
assis dans que ces plaintes pour
harcèlement sexuel et qu'il a été démis
de ses fonctions